do when I was growing up I don't know if
I told this throne here but they used to
have you know they have this rest area
you know where a lot of men would meet
and drug-induced homosexuality would
occur you know am I talking straight-up
natural homosexuality I'm talking to
drug-induced meaning you're on drugs and
then you're gay yeah you know you know a
gay when you're on drugs
yeah word so because that's a lot of
that's a baaad that's a side effect of a
lot of drugs you know and they don't put
that on the little bags ever that are
you might meet a buddy with a chat you
know and uh and so this some they had
these dudes that would shoot a lot of
men would meet up on this rest area do
drugs and then coagulate you know do the
thing yeah do all kinds of things and
stuff and so sometimes we would sit
across because I live across where I
lived they backed up to this river where
you could see across to the rest here
and the rest areas but behind the
interstate so there's a river between me
and the interstate and then between the
river and the interstate is the rest
area where and so we get one time we go
down there and there's these dudes man
these two big guys that are shooting
potatoes across this river with a potato
gun
they have binocular it's Louisville
potato anytime like two fellas we get a
little too quick and sit you will they
[ __ ] fire at are over at them there's
a process real good haters man talk
blockers I am welcoming [ __ ] block yeah
we didn't know what they were doing
we're like what are you guys doing and
they're like we're firing these tots
over at these boys over there on dope
and so he's looking tots to stop this
game so we start looking through the
binoculars and look man I mean uh yeah
anybody should be able to have sex with
anybody they want 100% dude I'll [ __ ]
your cousin bro but what I'm saying is
I'll [ __ ] your cousin blind
I'll go in blindfolded dude all in
before the deal all right
all right so whatever bro maybe he's gay
I'm not but what I'm saying is that the
the that it doesn't matter but these
guys were intent on stopping these
fellows but if they just hugged or
anything no tot but they started a
frickin if one of them started going if
they started it was really almost uh
vertical issue once they started getting
a little too container time yeah
can't even tied it up and they went on
lunch break and and we got to take over
me and my buddy firing these tossed it
we can only shoot him like to the middle
of the river though oh so then you saw
but it was fun is it kind of like a
Civil War Reenactment a little bit a
little bit yeah it had that vibe you
know kind of but anyway I'm just saying
that yeah that kind of stuff
that kind of stuff goes on man you know
what we talking about
you had some friends shooting tater tots
a gay guys there weren't friends of mine
do they were locals big difference man
my buddies when I don't think they would
do that what we did do it on lunch break
but that's just you didn't hit him use
you just it's just fun to fire him saw
potato gun we were the halftime show Oh
at college
really yeah people use having people
just shoot him across like like one
apartment complex had a bunch in another
apartment complex never much and they
would just shoot him in here to go to
school
Louisiana State over an University of
Arizona actually as well but people just
launched him you know this potato or
they were like rocket launcher it's kind
of dangerous yeah oh it's [ __ ]
vegetable Isis out there there if you
want angels man dude I saw a dude pull
up one time just stop hitting me fire
off two [ __ ] tots it's like you know
get back into a car [ __ ] it Jeff don't
even over there with dude they're
[ __ ] hard ya hit by a potato you know
ever Wow it [ __ ] you up you seem like
somebody would get shot at I agree chin
looks like looks like a bad guy from an
80s movie
dawg you gotta wear em you do use the
leather jacket rolled up yeah first day
I wear a leather jacket too I'm not
gonna oh wow yeah how do you feel in it
cuz I feel different in different types
of coats
I always feel the same yeah I wear
sweats all the time I always feel the
same when I dressed up in like a leather
jacket you feel different do you seem
different that thing yeah a little [ __ ]
you know yeah does a little cocky in it
seemed like Dan what the [ __ ] is that
yeah you know I agree even though I know
him yeah you called him a dream yeah did
I yeah you call him the dream that
[ __ ] yellow dream huh it's a Korean
Korean dream
I've had that ice cream flavor do Korean
dream I agree
the Koreans are full of dreams man we
saw this Asian guy could have been
Korean he was fell off a building when
he hit the bottom dreams came out of him
bro but dreams doing guts and blood no I
just mean you could just feel the
[ __ ] fragments of ideas and hope and
imagination fly out of his body that's
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]